in one of my latest videos I talked
about the Sunni and Shia and what some
of the differences between them are and
in that video on our main points is that
we shouldn't view them as two distinct
factions like like the Catholic and
Orthodox churches and Christianity for
example and this is not just because
they are both eterna sort of internally
diverse but also because even from a
generalizing perspective they aren't
even the two only branches of Islam in a
lot of YouTube videos I see there are
not just in YouTube viewers and
generally I see a lot of people making
were talking about Sufism as its own
branch so that it becomes Sunni Shia and
soupy but this is highly inaccurate
because Sufism is not a branch in itself
but Sufis are rather usually Sunnis or
Shia it's more of a dimension or
practice within Islam but there is
another branch that is distinct from
both Sunni and Shia and one that is sort
of often forgotten and not very much
talked about but if you do travel to the
country of Oman you'll find that a huge
number of the population maybe even a
majority follow this branch which is
known as Abadi ISM
[Music]
if you've never heard about your body
ISM don't worry and neither have most
people in the world including most
Muslims while they do make up a very
small percentage of the world's Muslims
they do make up a significant portion
even the sort of official version of
Islam in the country of Oman on the
Arabian Peninsula as well as some
populations in pockets in Tunisia and
Algeria in North Africa today the bodies
are often known or viewed as a very
moderate or tolerant version of Islam
and if we ignore the fact that this
seems to imply that the Sunnis and Shia
are into these things there is some
merit to this claim the bodies and the
people in Oman generally have shown a
great ability to coexist peacefully and
tolerantly with people from other Muslim
denominations and also from different
faiths altogether it made us be
surprising to learn that the body is
amiss simultaneously a rather
puritanical or strict interpretation of
Islam if those words are understood in a
more nuanced in neutral way simply as a
strict adherence to the religious law
these paradoxes will become clear as
soon but let's dive deeper and explore
what a body ism is all about and how it
came about they originated in an early
movement called the college or college
i'ts who seceded in protest from the
army of the fourth caliph Ali after he
had signed an agreement with the leader
of my idea from our we are following a
civil war between the two battle called
the Battle of Siffin
this group became known as the Huaraz or
Hara Knights based on the Arabic word to
leave the route Raja because they
seceded from his army it was also a
college I to a few years later in 661
assassinated Ali for his treason
according to them they would then
constitute their own group who was thus
distinct from both Sunnis and Shia and
would often be involved in different
revolts and sometimes violent
revolutions now the issue of the cottage
is a rather sensitive one it is true
that the bodies have their origins in
this movement and most bodies today sort
of accept this fact but they are
simultaneously kind of uneasy about it
which is understandable
the Hawara CH were viewed by their
contemporaries back in the classical
Islamic world as being extremists
violent extremists who would often
attack other Muslims because they didn't
believe in the same things that they did
to the point that today many people use
how RH has a very derogatory term to
describe groups like al-qaeda or Isis
and has thus become almost synonymous
with terrorists what's important to
remember that the cottage themselves
were back then divided into subgroups
not all of which were violent or as
extreme but nonetheless disagreed about
Ali's decision at the Battle of Siffin
it is often said that it was the
moderate branch of the college i'ts that
became the embodies often being for
example unfriendly terms with the
Umayyad regime and cooperating with them
and that they split off from the larger
college movement because of their
extremist views we're not exactly sure
when the bodies became a distinct group
of their own its founding is often
attributed to two figures Abdullah ibn
Abbas whom ableism is named after and
job in a bin zayed both of whom seem to
have died in the early 8th century the
latter figure jaboney bin zayed was from
Oman originally he studied and lived for
a while in Basra one of these centers of
the umayyad caliphates before eventually
moving back or possibly being expelled
with his followers to Oman and this
might be the start of a body zammis
strong presence in that country in
particular from that point on your body
ISM would develop into its own unique
tradition and while it sometimes was
rather isolated of course it didn't
develop in a vacuum
many of these scholars of Abadi ISM
studied ambassador and among many Sunni
and Shia scholars and thus were highly
influenced by those movements the
uniqueness and fasting aspects of the
body is Ammar course many but I will
place them historically and
intellectually within the larger Islamic
world through three main points or
subjects jurisprudence theology and
authority
in terms of the general aspects of law
or science of law known as Fidel v the
II bodies are pretty familiar they
basically follow the SUNY model they
adapted the sedan model from the Sunnis
probably which means that they they use
in terms of law driving law they use the
Quran primarily than the hadith and the
Sunna of the Prophet analogy and
consensus one way in which they differ
from the Sunnis is that they generally
tend to deny taco lead which is sort of
imitation of the established doctrine
which is something that the Sunnis
followed generally from the Middle Ages
to at least the early modern period
instead the Abadi is retain the
importance of the concept known as HD
HOD or personal reasoning of the
individual jurist which they share more
with the Shia than the Sunni as such
much like in the Sunni and Shia world
the hadith eventually became very
important and the bodies plays a large
emphasis on it however like the Shia the
bodies have their own hadiths and
collections of hadith primarily a
collection called the Tartabull Mossad
which was compiled in the 12th century
it contains some hadiths from the Sunna
collections but primarily those of an
earlier Abadi collection called the jama
sahi or most Nidal arabiya given that
this is basically the only Abadi
collection the ax bodies have a
significantly lesser number of hadiths
to work from compared to their Sunni and
Shia counterparts partly as a result of
this the bodies have some rather unique
practices when it comes to some of the
rituals like the daily prayers for
example the e bodies actually have their
hands down at the sides while praying in
the standing position which they share
with some Shia groups but not the
majority of Sunnis there are also
differences in some very minut details
like the fact that the bodies don't say
I mean after reciting the Alpha T huh
the opening prayer of the Quran
traditionally there has also been a
rather unique doctrine where no
congregational provide a prayers are to
be observed unless there is a just Imam
in power although this isn't really
enforced today
when it comes to issues of theology the
bodies are sometimes rather familiar and
at other times very unique much like the
rationalist eclis oriented theological
school called the Motta's Li Li
sunni-shia world the bodies tend to view
or read Quranic verses metaphorically at
least those describing God with
anthropomorphic qualities instead they
favor a God that is completely devoid of
creaturely qualities and that ISM sort
of absolutely transcendent in that sense
similarly they also hold that the sort
of essential attributes like life
knowledge wisdom and so on that God has
is not something that he has or is added
to his essence but it's actually part of
his essence so knowledge and wisdom is
not something that God has it's
something that he is in his very being
moreover the body's generally sure the
Motta's Allah position that the Quran
was created at a specific point in time
rather than being eternally present with
God like the mainstream Sunni position
however unlike the Motta's allied they
do not believe in free will but rather
that everything is preordained and
controlled by God much like these Suniel
Shetty's so as you can see in terms of
theology they have some aspects are
similar to to the Motta's Allah and and
the Shia in that sense and other factors
that are more similar to the Sunni
mainstream a Sharia theology certain
other unique doctrines of the huar edge
which the earlier bodies adopted were
rather strict ideas about who counted as
a Muslim according to them people who
sin are not Muslims anymore while the
mainstream Sunnis would say that
basically anyone who affirmed the basic
tenets of the faith were Muslims and
sinning made you perhaps a less good
Muslim the bodies would say that
behavior and actions were integral to
the faith as such being a Muslim meant
upholding certain standards and if you
didn't live up to those standards you
wouldn't count as a Muslim this is why
some of the college who held the same
idea felt like they could assassinate
Ali for example as they believed that he
had lost his right to lead but even if
people sinned and weren't considered
Muslims anymore to the bodies that were
usually still counted as monotheists and
retained certain rights one could
intermarry with them and so on one
should keep in mind
this is all the traditional and
classical approach of the bodies and
earlier wattage and that most sort of
Abadi scholars today probably wouldn't
agree with this rather many modern
scholars do it and sort of have a more
accumulative and open towards other
denominations and other religions
generally they often stand for things
like tolerance and peaceful coexistence
rather than these very strict ideas that
the traditionally bodies had
ideas of authority also differs
significantly from the Sunni and the
Shia the Shia obviously has a very clear
idea of authority with the Imams
so-called being both the worldly and
spiritual leaders and successors of
Mohammed and being exclusively from the
prophets sort of a lion succession
through his daughter Fatima to the
Sunnis at least in theory the caliphs
the leaders of the community should be
from the the tribe of the Quraysh which
is Muhammad's tribe back in Arabia and
was usually a hereditary position even
if the early ideal seemed to have been a
Calif elected by a community choice the
bodies in contrast don't take tribal or
family affiliation into account at all
they also call their leaders Imams but
these Imams don't hold the same
spiritual role that they do and she ISM
the Imam of the bodies is elected by a
group of religious scholars or ulama
based solely on his PID righteousness
and ability to lead because of the
strong emphasis on the character of the
Imam and which can be traced back to the
early days of the Huaraz the embodies
therefore also has a rather unique idea
that if there is an unfit Imam in power
one who is not righteous or doesn't lead
well it is not only allowed but
encouraged to depose him in a kind of
revolt there is a saying that as long as
you have 40 men who are willing to die
you ought to depose any unjust leader
this doctrine of the bodies is also why
like I mentioned earlier they have held
traditionally that no congregational
fiery prayers are to be observed at all
unless there's a just Imam in power this
is connected to this idea of authority a
land or nation that is ruled by a
righteous Imam is called an imam it and
there had been a few ybody Imam it's in
history there were some early on in
North Africa but most have been in Oman
and Zanzibar in East Africa which was
part of an Omani Empire for a while the
last of these Imam its was established
in 1913 by an ordinal salami and the
last of the Imams was available in I who
died in 2009 the Sultanate of Muscat and
Imam it of a man so-called was unified
as the Sultanate of Oman in 1970 and
thus ended the last moment the whole
area has been since ruled by Sultan's
sort of more secular leaders the latest
of which was Sultan Qaboos bin Saeed who
actually just passed away on January
10th this year may he rest in peace
so what we have with the body ISM is
what appears to be a rather paradoxical
situation the scholar Valerie J Hoffman
has written an excellent book called the
essentials of Abadi Islam in which he
points out that a body 'some appears to
present a number of contradictory
positions at least according to our
often preconceived notions about
religion or Islam in general a body ISM
is to a large degree a rather
puritanical movements as putting great
emphasis on following the law of the
Sharia but at the same time they apply a
rather rational theology similar to the
Motta's law these are often two
positions that we don't see going
together they believe in predestination
but still believe in both the
creativeness of the quran and have a
strong sort of activist tendency they
also have a rather narrow and
restrictive definition of what
constitutes a Muslim but at the same
time seems to show great tolerance and
understanding for those non-muslims in
fact this is something that is important
to remember much of what I've said in
this video has been from a historical
traditional standpoint and doesn't
necessarily apply at all to the present
situation a body is often like to view
themselves and are viewed by others as
moderates and a tolerant branch of Islam
we can see this in Oman as many
different religious groups live
side-by-side peacefully and the general
attitude of about these scholars towards
those of other denominations are usually
accumulate the body ISM deserves more
attention and discussion not just
because of its apparent tolerance today
which is of course admirable but also
because it's a significant unique and
and very interesting branch of Islam
that is often forgotten in these kinds
of discussions but at the same time it
can tell us a lot about the complexity
and diversity of this religion I'll see
you next time
[Music]